thank you osamu
okay so i'm going to be talking about
algorithms for quantified boolean
formulas um
so some of this is based on joint work
with ryan williams and and the
restaurant joint work with ruben chen
um so throughout this talk i'm going to
try to make things as simple as possible
and if that's not simple enough i'll
make them even simpler um probably the
most challenging part will be my
handwriting so if you have any issues
with reading anything or anything else
let me know
so the
the basic structure of the talk i'm
going to start with
just describing kind of a high level
perspective on the connections between
algorithms and lower bounds because a
lot of the talks today deal with those
connections
um and then i'm going to go on to give
some of the the basic background for
this problem uh and state our results
and i hope to give
basically the complete proofs of at
least a couple of these results that
should be completely understandable
that's what i'm shooting for
um and then i'll end with um
if there's time with the conjecture
which i think might be interesting um so
if you went to the boot camp i think
there's something that you might find
interesting
okay um so to begin with so there's well
this whole workshop is about connections
between algorithms and lower bounds and
such connections in some form or another
have existed for for quite a long time
um but more recently they've taken the
form of
connections between uh satisfiability
algorithms um
and circuit low bounds so essentially
you have algorithms for these problems
such as circuit satisfiability or what
srikant spoke about yesterday which is
the compression problem where you have
the truth table of a boolean function
and if that boolean function has small
circuits you want to somehow compute a
smaller representation of the boolean
function um in time polynomial in the
size of the truth table so that's the
compression problem and the satisfying
problem of course is just that you're
given a circuit and you want to know
whether it's satisfiable or not
and somehow you want non-trivial
algorithms for these problems
and such non-trivial algorithms yield
circuit low bounds
so there's a result of ryan williams
which says that satisfiability
algorithms for most natural classes of
circuits give circuit low bounds
and um there's a result due to valentine
others which says that compression
algorithms give give lower bounds um so
i guess these can be thought of as
approaches to proving circuit low bounds
um and given that uh we've been stuck on
showing low bounce or explicit functions
for quite a long time now um this this
is a viable approach and
although it's not as strong in that it
only proves low balance for exponential
time classes so far like non-text
exponential time
it still represents some progress
but some of these algorithms that you
design um for satisfiability or
compression um well the question is
where do they come from right so um you
have to be somehow able to design and
analyze these algorithms and to do that
you somehow had exploit some properties
of the circuit class c um so in in this
talk i'm going to be interested more in
this reverse connection so um uh which
probably has seen
actually even more work than um than the
connection from arguments to lower
bounds which is using ideas from low
bounds and complexity theory to design
algorithms right
and kind of at a at a very high level
what's happening is that somehow you're
using some property queue of functions
that are computed by small circuits and
you're trying to exploit the property to
give algorithms for satisfiability of
the compression problem that are
non-trivial
um so for example such a property could
be um for uh ac 0 circuits um that they
have decision trees of non-trivial size
which is true
or for for formulas for demorgan
formulas of subquadratic size that again
they have decision trees of non-trivial
size um and in the case of acc0 that
they have a representation as depth 2
circuits where
the bottom level consists of ions a
small fanon and the top level is a
symmetric gate so these are all
properties in some cases we can actually
find a function explicitly that
doesn't have the property and thereby
prove an explicit low bound but in other
cases such as with acc0 we don't know
how to do that we only know how to
indirectly prove a low bound by going
through this connection after using the
property to design an algorithm
but in general kind of the lesson is
that if
a circuit classy has some kind of
weakness some kind of property
in terms of representations that are
simpler or something of that kind then
um we can hope to get better algorithms
for that corresponding circuit class
and this is a question is of course of
independent interest because um
satisfied algorithms are
important a lot of context such as
verification and automated planning and
so on and so forth
and there has been um
quite a bit of work on satisfactory
algorithms for various classes such as
cnfs
constant depth circuits formula sat and
so on
but in this talk i'm going to um try for
something that's that somehow seems even
harder which is others not just for
satisfiability but for quantified
boolean formulas
um but before going to that i'd just
like to say what we're trying to achieve
right so we can't really hope for
polynomial algorithms to these problems
because these would have implications
such as np equals p or p space equals p
so um we have to really restrict our our
ambitions
um so we have this notion of the savings
of an algorithm which is somehow gives
you kind of an
estimate of how much the algorithm is
saving or the trivial algorithm
so for a problem we say it has savings r
if the algorithm runs in time to the n
minus r and i guess i need to be clear
about what capital r and capital n are
so capital n is just some kind of
indication of the effective dimension of
the problem so if you have um a
satisfying problem it's just a number of
variables so if um brute force search
would run in time that's two to the n um
throughout this talk i'll be suppressing
kind of a polynomial factor in the
instance size itself which occurs
together with this so i'll only be
talking about the exponential factor
mostly
um so the question is well how much can
we save over this trivial brute force
search that runs in time two to the n
and that's represented by this savings
function r
and i'm deliberately being kind of
imprecise about
how r depends on n because it might not
depend just on n but some other
parameters of the instance as we'll see
but in general it's somehow the number
of bits you can save over the dimension
of the brute force search and our goal
will be to
to
have as high and r as possible right if
we want to get a low running time we
want an r that's as large as possible
um
so now to the problem that we're
considering this is going to be the
quantified boolean kind of
satisfiability problem
and in general we consider it for a
class capital c of circuits um
so an instance of the problem is just um
well a quantified boolean circuit um so
you have
quantified variables x1 to xn and here
each of the qr's is in that exists for
all
so all the variables are quantified
either existentially or universally and
then you have some circuit of these of
these variables right um
and the question is well is this formula
psi true or not
um and we can ask this for questions
this question for various uh class of
circuits capital c where c comes from
various class of circuits capital c
um
okay so um any questions so far is this
clear
so um just to give you an example
of a quantified boolean satisfactory
problem consider this formula psi um so
it's just that exists for all y there
exists z where you have this c and f
here
um
and well the trivial brute force search
way to solve this is using this kind of
and or tree evaluation where you just
have a tree where um well the root is
labeled by the first quantified variable
um its children are labeled by a second
quantified variable and so on and so
forth
and the leaves just correspond to
evaluations of this
of this
function c
on the corresponding path right the path
is represented by a binary string which
is an assignment to x y z etc etc and
the leaf just corresponds to an
evaluation of c on that
and now in order to determine the truth
of this of this formula you can just do
kind of a recursive algorithm i mean a
trivial recursive algorithm works where
you essentially
call the algorithm at the root and if
it's an existential node then it's an or
of its children the value is the or of
the values of its children and if it's a
universal node it's the end of its value
of value to its children
and you get um kind of a recursive
algorithm in this way which runs in time
two to the capital n right times some
some polynomial in the instance size
um
well so
unlike in satisfyability so a lot of the
algorithms for satisfiability
are based on kind of somehow finding the
witness so
you either use branching or you use
local search or some other technique to
find a small witness here of course we
don't have small witnesses i mean a
witness here is something of this sort
um so you have kind of for each
existential node you have one child
that's chosen and for each universal
node you have both traditions and so
that's a proof tree so this is an
exponential size object a proof tree and
the proof tree certifies somehow the
value of this instance um so that the
usual kind of algorithmic paradigms for
satisfactory don't seem to quite work in
this context to give anything uh
interesting
but nevertheless we'll see that our
athletic approach is based on uh somehow
reducing to satisfyability
so an important parameter here
throughout is going to be this parameter
k which is somehow the number of
quantified blocks right so i'm assuming
throughout the instances in print x
normal form so the variables are all
quantified and then you're evaluating a
circuit on the on on those on those
values um and well so the variables are
quantified in different ways but if you
consider a maximal kind of block of
variables that's quantified the same way
that's what we call a quantifier block
so there could be a long block of
existential variables and then block of
universal variables and so on
and that's what capital k is and it
turns out that the complexity of this
problem is is kind of closely tied to
what k is at least as far as we know um
and i'll try to be trying to explain how
um how that works
um okay so that's the setup for the
problem um any questions so far
so now more the results so um we have
some upper bounds and we have some
connections to um to circuit lower
bounds um
so um
this this result here is drawn to the
ruben and the others are with ryan um so
the upper bounds are um well so for qb c
and f set um so where this circuit here
is just a c and formula um we have
savings that's omega of n to the one
over k plus one so uh remember that k is
just a number of quantifier blocks so
when you have a small number of
quantifier blocks we can get quite
significant savings um for uh for for
qbc and fsat this is still not quite as
significant as you can for
satisfiability where quite often you can
get linear savings or close to linear
savings but we'll see that somehow
going beyond this will take uh new ideas
so that's what cnf said um well so for
quantified boolean circuit set so um
this seems pretty much hopeless because
well circuit sat is a problem that we
don't know how to beat root for search
for at all um the best thing we know is
the trivial algorithm um but if the
number of quantified blocks is large
then we can get non-trivial savings here
so this is somehow a difference um from
between the polynomial time setting and
the exponential time setting because in
the normal time setting well you think
of p space as being harder than np but
when you think about exact complexity
sometimes um something like having more
alternations can help you design a
faster algorithm
and this is actually almost this result
is almost immediate from
from some previous work i'll describe
how later on in the talk
but i'd like to point out that these two
results together so this was that of
course also works for c and f's
what those two results together imply
somehow that the hard range of k is k
that's between log n over log log n and
k equals log n so when you have a
logarithmic number of quantifiers that's
when we don't know how to get
non-trivial savings so generally
speaking um
the the regime where non-trivial sayings
are hard is somehow the the hard kind of
set of instances and here when k is
little of log n or log log n we have
non-trivial savings namely sayings omega
of log n so anything that's better than
log n we call non-trivial so when k is
small we have non-trivial saying from
this result when k is larger not same
from this result and it's only the k in
the middle that we're somehow not able
to deal with
so these are results for cnf sat and
circuit set um and for formula sat we
have a result that's that's quite close
to this that um the savings again is
where you have an n to the omega 1 over
k and omega 1 ok in the exponent
but this only works for small formulas
so it only works when the formula size
is n to the 5 4 minus omega 1. but you
would expect that because
even to solve satisfiability we don't
know how to do that when say the formula
size is more than cubic um and that's
closer related to the question of
proving low bounds for formulas of size
more than cubic um so somehow you expect
some kind of constraint on the formula
size here because the quantified boolean
formula problem is harder than the
formula side problem
okay so that's about upper bounds um so
you could wonder about how much you
could hope to improve these results
because they seem like mild improvements
or brute force search um
well i mean it's kind of like a
sub-exponential improvement a factor
improvement but well maybe you can get
something better than this omega n
well what we show is we don't quite rule
this out we don't give a hardness result
but we give a different kind of result
we show that modulo the current state of
knowledge and complexity theory this is
essentially the best we can hope to do
if we improved any of these algorithms
then
we would actually get new low bounds
and we do this by kind of connecting
improved algorithms for these problems
to circuit low bounds so um
so in general if you had nontrivial
savings namely sayings omega of log n
for qbc and fsat if you have that for
any range of parameters so um savings
that doesn't depend on k somehow it's
always omega of log n then you'd get
that um nx doesn't have polynomial size
formulas so by nc one here i mean the
non-uniform class not the uniform class
which is clearly strictly contained in x
so you get non-uniform boolean formula
low bounds for nx if you have savings
omega of log n um
well then you might ask how about the
low quantify block regime how about the
regime where k is small uh what if you
had a good savings there that's better
than what we have well there again if
you've got um
kind of an end to the omega one over k
savings so if you have some function
here that's a little omega one over k um
that would also imply new formula size
lower bounds that would also imply that
an x plus not an nc one
so um in some sense these these two
results together are kind of tight model
of what we know in complexity theory so
far
okay any questions
um
so what i'm going to do is i'm going to
first tell you
this algorithm um so it's fairly simple
to describe and simple to analyze um
i'll try to give some intuition for it
at first and then hopefully tell you the
whole algorithm and its analysis um
then i say something about this result
which actually it pretty much follows
from what is already known and but you
just need to look at it the right way
and i'll tell you about that um and then
if time permits let's say a little bit
of the connections to low bounds um and
also about this conjecture that i
mentioned
okay
yeah what is the difference between one
and two in these connections
um
between uh this one and this one i mean
what is the difference
well so um
yeah
both cases but here the savings don't
you're not
kind of referring to k at all so you
want savings
yeah that's n so it's omega of log n
irrespective of k and here you just want
a better dependence on k yeah
so intuitively this refers to the kind
of the regime where k is small and
you're asking about improvements there
and this just refers to the whole kind
of yeah range of k
oh it's n to the omega sub k 1 over k so
for example if you had um n to the log k
over k or something of that sort rather
than enter the constant over k so yeah
if you had any kind of improvement here
uh any kind of factor here that's uh
that's omega one yeah
it's something growing with k yeah yeah
but basically the constant factor here
is related to the kind of the polynomial
size low bounds you get here so if you
had um something that's super constant
here you get super polynomial so it's
slow bounce
yeah
it's important to note that in point one
you only need that to hold
that's right yeah so um
you you may not want to log in or log in
and log in but yeah yeah because as i
said before you already have non-trivial
savings
yeah yeah
can i have to get super logger things
fake savings when from quantum product
boxes
yeah yeah i mean the number of blocks is
small or very large we have savings not
trivial already so essentially we just
need to get this for k equals theta log
n or somewhere around that range and
that would give you a lower bounds and
as you'll see the algorithms that we
have are fairly simple so well it
doesn't seem too impossible that
something more sophisticated could could
give you a better algorithm but then
again maybe the problem is so on
structure that you can't really hope to
do anything more so it depends whether
an optimist or a pessimist and also when
what being an optimist means doesn't
mean you prove lower bounds or give
algorithms that's the other question um
so um yeah
okay so now i'm going to
start talking about the result one so
i'll first give you some basic intuition
for it so like a basic approach when you
only have two quantifier blocks so
that's what i'm going to start off with
so let's say you have
psi actually let me switch this around
so when i write things in this way these
are vectors of variables so i'm just
like these are this is the case where
there are two blocks there's one
universal block and then one existential
block um
and the question is well um is this
formula side true um so how do you hope
to analyze this right so this is the
first case beyond satisfiability um so
what we're going to do is rely on
satisfied algorithms for c and f's and
more generally for constant depth
circuits so we're going to try to reduce
this problem to a satisfaction for cnfs
and for constant depth circuits
um
so in in one case here when um this this
the size of y is large so this
essentially two cases so um
if
size of y
is bigger than n to the epsilon
i'll kind of say more about epsilon
later so if this quantified block is
large then um
brute force
our x
and solve
c f set
on p sub x of y
okay so if this quantify block is large
um then what we can do is we can just
try all possible values for for this
quantify block x um and for each such
setting we now have a cnf in the
variables y but now y is a large block
so we can just use the cnfsat algorithm
um for um that this formula when x has
been restricted um to get significant
savings in terms of y so that savings
will be close to n to the epsilon right
so in this case we're done so this is
kind of an easier case but what we do in
the other case so what we do in case y
is small
well then
we're going to do somehow the opposite
we're going to brute force over y but
but what does it mean um it means that
you're going to basically convert this
part of psi to a depth 3 circuit so
you're going to take an or over all
possible settings of y um there's 2 to
the n to the epsilon 0 settings
and you're going to take phi of x y and
all of all those
kind of evaluations and that's going to
give you a depth 3 circuit there's now
sides 2 to the n to the epsilon times
polynomial in n
and if y is small then you know that x
is large
and then you can hope to solve
satisfaction for the depth 3 circuit so
the depth 3 circuit is still not too big
it's 2 to the n to the absolute epsilon
is small so we have still some hope of
solving it non-trivially so that's the
idea here
then
okay
so now c is something that depends only
on x and you just solve the satisfied
department c but for this of course we
do need satisfied algorithms for depth
three circuits and not just for
polynomial size definitely circuits but
for larger depth three circuits for size
to the entry epsilon but of course
epsilon is
is kind of up to us to choose we can
decide when we do do this and when we do
this so if you choose like um to be
epsilon something like um yeah i guess
one fourth or something like that then
you get some some something non-trivial
here some non-trivial
savings um but unfortunately well
at least the way we did it we tried
using this idea and we got some savings
but um the savings here were exponential
in k rather than rather than k so um
that didn't give us very good bounce
and so we need to modify this approach
so i'm going to now describe to you the
modified approach which in a way is
actually cleaner than what we're doing
here so we can actually hope to extend
this to more quantifier blocks but
that's not the approach we take we
instead do things a slightly different
way
so um so how do we do things um well in
order to state what we do we we first
need this kind of lemma which comes from
work by russell mohan um
and william matthews
so they have a satisfied argument for
constant depth circuits which we can
kind of inspect and interpret in a
certain way which gives us lemma here
oh sorry
just out of habit i think
so there's an algorithm which given a
circuit um
c
of a certain size and a certain depth so
size s and depth d
now it just doesn't just solve
satisfiability but it outputs the truth
table of c
and there's a trivial way of doing this
so the trivial way of doing this would
be to
try all possible inputs at 2 to the n of
them and for each one evaluate the
circuit so that takes time 2 to the n
times s
but
what we can get using the result is
something better
so in time order or tilde because i'm
suppressing polynomial factors of 2 to
the n
plus
s times 2 to the n
minus n
of the log
okay so is this expression clear so um
somehow we're saving all the trivial way
of outputting the truth table of a
boolean function right so the trivial
way we just evaluate the function on
every possible input and each evaluation
would be take time s and there's two to
the n inputs they'll take time to the n
times s but we want to get something um
that's kind of like a sum of two to the
n and something depending on s instead
so that's the the non-trivial part of it
now if you're thinking just about
satisfiability what um the imp result
gives you is is something like this
right so it gives you satisfactory
algorithm and running in this amount of
time
but somehow the structural kind of
properties of a 0 circuits that they use
and
and in fact used algorithmically can be
kind of exploited to give this kind of
well it's not a stronger result but it
somehow is morally stronger because
you're not just getting an answer to the
question whether there is a one but
you're getting every eval you're getting
every value of the of the circuit
right um and it's useful to kind of
think about parameters here so um
up to s being about n to the one over d
minus one this gives you something
non-trivial in terms of savings over
just evaluating the circuit on every
possible input okay
so that's important for us so it's
actually important that we have a linear
term here but it's also important that
this works up to s that's exponential
because if the algorithm only works for
polynomial s then
we can't really use this idea here and
and related ideas
okay so um is that clear
so how we're going to use that
so the idea is just memorization so it's
fairly simple to describe so let's say
you have a formula psi which is um
yeah let's say that exists x1
for all x2
and so on
um
and then some c of x1
in fact i want you to see it will be
better to use
this is the cnf here so what we're going
to do is we're going to kind of break up
the variables into two blocks so we're
going to somehow partition things so um
we're going to look at the first n prime
variables where n prime equals
n minus n to the one over k plus two
so this argument i'm going to tell you
now actually get savings omega of n to
the one or k plus two but just with a
kind of a small additional trick you can
get the savings that i um that i claimed
there so i'm just going to tell you the
simpler kind of argument here
so you you you take these this first
block of n-prime variables
um and then um
well the remaining variables so there's
remaining quantified waivers with n to
one or k plus two of them
so you just kind of convert this part of
the formula now into a constant f
circuit
so how do you do that well you just
brute force
over the quantified variables
to get a circuit
so there's now a circuit of size um
2 to the n to the 1 over k plus 2.
and depth at most k plus 2.
right so i mean here you have at most
k kind of quantifier blocks um so that's
when you're taking when you're kind of
doing the brute force of the variable
assignments that gives you k levels um
depth k and then the c f itself is of
depth two so you get two additional
levels so you get a depth k plus two
circuit and this is size two to the n to
the 1 or k plus 2 because you're brute
forcing all these variables here and
there's almost n to the one over k plus
2 of them right so this is a constant
depth circuit of of this size and this
depth
um and and this brute forcing here is
precisely what i did earlier where and
earlier there was just that one kind of
existential quantifier and it took a big
r now i'm going to take a big and of all
the vans and so on right
um so so this is some circuit c
and now of course the the truth of psi
is equivalent to um this kind of
sequence of kind of quantifications of
whether c of that set of variables is
true or not right so um
so now psi is equivalent to c of um
well
the x is x 1 and so on of c of
x 1 and so on but only until x and prime
right now we have a circuit on only n
prime variables
i'm confused about the do the the
breaking up with the
uh the how it interacts with the
alternations of the quantifier um
well okay so um
so suppose you have um oh okay i see so
you're you don't care you don't care
about that alternation right you don't
care where it comes yeah you don't care
where you're breaking up things
basically right i mean so you just do it
always after n prime variables and then
the rest of it is just n to the one k
plus two and you just brute force over
all the systems
yeah yeah actually that's yeah so we
don't care if it's pretty in the middle
that actually helps us quite a bit here
not kind of respecting these block
boundaries
okay so basically doing this and using
memorization together the lemma we had
earlier essentially gives you the result
so um
let me explain why
okay so now we have the circuit on um
just n prime variables so there's just
um
n prime variables here right and n prime
is something uh smaller than n and now
you just do the trivial algorithm the
brute force search algorithm right so
the trivial algorithm is just to
well take x1 and then x2
and you get a tree and this tree has
depth n prime right and then you have
these kind of leaves and the leaf each
leaf is an evaluation of the circuit on
on values and boolean values
so there's two to the n prime such
leaves
so now the trivial way of kind of doing
the brute force search would be um well
okay so you get to a leaf and then you
evaluate the circuit on that on that
input and that's going to take time
that's uh proportional to the size of
the circuit it's true to the n to one or
k plus two so you'll get to the n prime
n prime plus n to the one of k plus two
which doesn't give you anything at all
but of course we have this lemma this
lemma gives us kind of a more efficient
way of computing the truth table of a
constant depth circuit so what you do is
you just compute the truth table of c
and and memo wise so compute
truth table of c
n time
so if you think about the parameters
this is essentially 2 to the n minus n
to the 1 over k plus 2
and store it
so each time that you you you need the
answer to see on some input you can just
look up this table um that's just
exponential time and output the answer
right so it takes two time approximately
this much to kind of run imp and get the
truth table and then to do this brute
force search now by using memorization
rather than evaluating the circuit gets
you on the two to the n prime which is
the same answer right so the total time
is just two to the n prime plus this
time for storing the truth table um and
so you get order two n prime
all right
so um so that's the basic idea um and it
seems like somehow all the magic is
hidden in imp
and and though imp is very nice result
essentially using the switching lemma
and optimizing the switching lemma so
why are we getting something here
um it's kind of subtle i think it's
because um in some sense when you're
trying to solve qbf's um your the order
of variables is enforced on you so
you've got to explore in this order
because you can't switch the order of
quantification but somehow when you have
this constant depth circuit um there you
can kind of in in terms of running a
satellite diagram for that circuit um
exploring variables in different orders
actually helps you in fact that's what
imp does they have kind of a branching
algorithm which explores the variables
in different orders so there you can
kind of switch the order in which to
explore variables and that gives you
some advantage i mean this probably
doesn't make any sense to people who
haven't thought about the problem but
yeah but that's that's a basic
conclusion
but hopefully the proof is completely
clear right so hopefully every step is
clear so the alternation of quantifiers
before you break it that doesn't matter
that doesn't matter at all yeah yeah it
doesn't matter yeah how many how many
quantifiers there are there could be
more than
yeah yeah yeah exactly yeah um i mean
basically um you need that um there
aren't too many quantifier alternations
to the end here so in the last end to
the one or k plus two variables you
don't have too many quantifier
alternations
you can even handle
rapid alternations at the beginning it's
just at the end you shouldn't have too
many alternations
okay so that's this result um
so now let's talk maybe briefly about
the second result
okay so um for the second result it
actually just follows from like known
results about um the the zero error um
query complexity of and or tree
evaluation right so the and dot three
evaluation problem is just that you have
uh like a balanced formula with ions and
odds
and of course you keep alternating and
then you have of course values of the
leaves
and you want to evaluate this formula
and the question is how many values you
need to read yes paul uh so the inp
algorithm is a randomized algorithm yeah
so that's something i'm suppressing so
all these results of a zero error
randomized algorithm so imp algorithm is
a zero randomized algorithm um so so is
this result here it's a zero or a
randomized algorithm um
yeah yeah it also applies to lower
bounds so all these kind of connections
hold when you have zero randomized
algorithms yeah
okay so um yeah so and dot tree
evaluation is just where you have a
balanced kind of formula and um you want
to evaluate it and how many um values
you need to read well so um there's a
famous result of uh
well i guess uh sneer first and then
saxon vic doesn't show it was tight
which is that um and or evaluation
um
on two to the n
size
um
formulas
but you do need the formula to be
structured in this way all these
alternations can be done
so you get um some kind of a savings
exponent here so 0.753 n and the idea is
very simple right in fact i can uh i can
explain it um so what's the idea so you
want to evaluate this kind of formula
and you know that there are lots of
alternations in it um
well um so suppose that the value the
actual the true value is a zero right
that means that one of these two nodes
should evaluate to a zero but if you
just choose kind of a child at random
and then evaluate it then probably half
you'll get the answer right away you'll
get a zero right away well well with
probably half you'll have to wait for
the other child to get the zero because
if this is zero one of the two children
is a zero um and if you know that a
child is zero you know that the and is
going to be a zero right so somehow
you don't need to explore both branches
in expectation you need to explore three
half's branches so essentially this
makes the branching factor three halves
rather than two which gets your savings
the more alternations you have
so this is of course when you have the
answer being a zero but if the answer is
a one then both of these children are
ones and then you get the same kind of
branching um factor improvement in in
both of these children just by duality
so if the orders are one then both
children here must be one and similarly
both shown in here must be one and then
exploring the tree at random is going to
give you the right answer without having
to explore both children and expectation
you just need to explore three halves so
somehow this kind of improvement you get
with the branching factor that you
expect is three halves rather than there
are rather than two for each alternation
um and this idea that they use but this
of course generalizes to say that when
you have k alternations then you get um
kind of savings omega of k because each
time you improve on the branching factor
that's like an omega 1 savings in the
exponent of your algorithm um so so
that's how you get uh on this result
here but um yeah
and of course you get it for circuit set
but rather because you don't really care
what these values here are you can kind
of it's a decision free result you can
just read these values um and then you
still get the same result you're not
you're using the fact that
c has some structure whereas for these
results you do use that um use that fact
um and for this and for this third upper
bound here um
well it's kind of like a more kind of
complicated version of this um so you
kind of like
try to do the same thing but now
um
well i guess i've i've addressed the
part where i was blowing up this the
quantifier blocks to get a constant
depth circuit now you won't get an ac 0
circuit but an ac 0 circuit with small
formulas at the leaves um and you need
to
prove a result of this kind for such for
such circuits and and and that's what
roon and i do and get this
get the savings in this case as well
okay any questions
so let me very briefly in the few
minutes i have left
give you at least a basic idea of these
of these connections to lower bounds
so what they rely on is this kind of
this result of ryan that i told you
about earlier
so if you have savings
omega of log n
for c sat
and this holds for a variety of a class
of circuits you just need some basic
closure operations then this implies
that next is not in c
um and now somehow we want to deal with
c being formulas right um well our
savings are just for qbc and fsat but we
want to um prove this kind of
implication that next is not an nc one
that it doesn't have on size formulas
so um
we essentially encode formulas in terms
of c and f's by using slightly more
alternations that's the idea
so um
there are two lemmas that we have and
those give you these two results so the
first one says that there is a polytime
reduction
which
given
formula
v um so this is just an boolean formula
of arbitrary depth um
outputs
an equivalent
q b c and f
with
n plus order log n variables so this is
a critical part you need to
somehow do this reduction so you need to
somehow reduce formulas to qbc and s but
without adding too many additional
variables you add only very few
variables and intuitively this kind of
order login corresponds to the depth of
the formula for each level of the
formula you can assume it's balanced for
each level you somehow add a variable
and use quantification cleverly so that
you're able to get such a reduction
and now how does um
how does this result follow from from
this theorem this lemma well um we want
to solve formula sat better than brute
force search so we first applied the
reduction and get kind of an instance of
qbc and fsat and then um by this kind of
assumption we get savings omega log n
there so you also get savings omega log
n for formulas at and that gives you
that next biz is not an nc one right um
and we have kind of an analogous lemma
for the other case where if you also
insist that you don't add too many extra
kind of quantifier blocks if you only
add k 25 blocks then the order log n is
n to the one over k essentially uh and
of course this follows the special case
of that and um and from there we get
this kind of
second connection between algorithms and
low bars
so i guess i'll have almost no time left
to tell you about this this conjecture
but um
well i think it's it's something
interesting and that was inspired by
this kind of
decision tree uh for uh um for for andor
evaluation
and um i thought about this conjecture
and as a victim of some anticipatory
plagiarism by russell i believe because
in the boot camp he talked about the
same kind of conjecture
and that's that
essentially if you have um kind of a
circuit set well if you have
an algorithm for some property of
boolean functions expressed succinctly
which is better than
just kind of querying the answers to
this boolean function on various values
then that should somehow morally give
you a circuit low bound right so
satisfiability can be thought of as like
succinct or and well dear randomization
can be thought of as a succinct version
of approximate majority um so well what
about succinct and or evaluation so
that's what this is here but now you
don't want just an algorithm of this
form you want an algorithm that beats
this and you want to show that such an
algorithm implies circuit low bound
somehow because if you had an algorithm
that was beating this it was beating
what you could do using decision trees
then in some sense you must be
exploiting the structure of the circuit
and
morally that should lead to circular
bounds but we just don't know how to
show that
we don't have that many connections
between algorithms and circuit low bonds
so
i think that's an interesting kind of
direction to think about because
we do have various algorithmic ideas but
there aren't that many different ways of
connecting algorithms to lower bounds
so that's all i have to say thanks
so i was wondering uh there's a
synthetic
conjecture
i'm thinking about the manual stuff
on the nc zero reduction how do you
think this might help or
uh kind of make it more difficult
or to prove this so the conjecture that
russell had um so um
yeah i'm not sure so that definitely
gives you kind of more efficient
reductions but there the focus is on
efficiency right it's on kind of um
tying the kind of the the class for
which you have better meta algorithmic
results um closely to uh the class which
have low bounds
but but somehow here you want to um
yeah you want to prove kind of
low bounce based on different things so
that works based on satisfiability you
want to base to you want to prove low
bounce based on other properties of
boolean functions
other than the or or the approximate
majority you want to somehow generalize
that and say for any property of boolean
functions maybe satisfying some
conditions um doing that non-trivially
when you're given a succinct
representation would give you low bounds
but i don't really have
ideas on on how to do them really
thought about it
seems to be uh easier to
uh obtain uh efficient algorithms than
than to prove lower bounds but in other
settings it's the opposite uh
for instance it seems to be easier to
obtain arithmetic circuit or balance
than you then together in the mice pit
do you have a
an intuition why is this difference well
i mean if you look at white box isn't it
the case that often you have that when
you don't have low bonds or
there are some cases
where you have that and don't have low
bounds
i mean i'm not sure i mean it's true
that
the kind of
low bounds follow almost immediately
from from kind of denomination but the
other way usually there's incurs some
loss right so that's that's kind of an
issue um at least in the boolean setting
i can say that somehow algorithm should
be morally simpler than low bonds i mean
if you have a low bound for some class
that you can prove explicitly then you
should be able to mine that argument
technique to get an algorithm to mind
the proof technique to get an algorithm
i mean we don't always know how to do
this but
morally that should be the case i think
there isn't a formal connection between
low bounce and from low bonds to
algorithms but intuitively that should
be the case
it seems to be
easier to first come up with an
algorithm
and then to
write because
because when you think of proofs we're
already thinking algorithmically in some
sense so i mean that might be why we
already come up with albums and also i
think maybe the arithmetic setting is
slightly different than the boolean
setting because there's more structure
there so maybe um
that also changes the kind of situation
slightly i mean i i guess i don't have
as much intuition for the arithmetic
settings for boolean setting
yeah
so
what
kind of improvement would you like there
and for which inputs inputs are let's
say nc1 formulas for example and but
then what would you like the exponent to
be um well no no so the inputs so if you
have just a c and f so quantify boolean
c and f um where um
well yeah we have kind of um an
improvement that's omega of k maybe
right so for
something that gives you something for k
equals log n or something like that yeah
so that would imply new lower bounds
already we know that k equals log n
we're fine but um
in this decision you have the leaves out
of this quantified
formula but
in the running time so of course if the
inputs are arbitrary you cannot beat
that yeah you can't beat that so so i'm
not
just wondering i mean
forget the undermined algorithms how
about non-deterministic algorithms
non-deterministic algorithms you cannot
beat square root but would square would
be okay um well the thing is that you
want to exploit the fact that the leaves
are computed by cnfs i mean that's yeah
yeah yeah yeah
yeah so if you're trying to solve um
yeah a non-terminal with better kind of
running time for cns would be
interesting i think definitely basically
you want to improve this kind of omega k
here to something better yeah i mean so
any kind of better dependence on k at
all would be interesting that means that
uh yeah square root will not be good
enough if you want little of k um
omega of k yeah yeah oh my god
yeah yeah yeah yeah that's right yeah so
somehow you want to explore the fact
that you have cnfs i mean that's the
that's the key thing to get better
okay so thank you very much